Joshua Childress is a 37 year old father
of two who spent seven years as a u.s.
Border Patrol agent out of Arizona's
Yuma Station tracking footprints to
catch illegal crossers he resigned last
month after changing his mind about
illegal immigration I went in because I
have a background in the military it was
something I was good at and it seemed
like something that needed done my
understanding of the laws at the time
was that there were proper ways to get
into this country legally and that the
people that were coming across were just
shirking those laws
what is the border situation there is
there a fence or a wall what kind of
obstacles are people trying to get
around most of our area does have
fencing infrastructure there are parts
that have barriers that just will stop
vehicles how did people get past that oh
they would just climb over would a wall
going across the entire border be useful
and stop people from coming over I don't
think so it's been my experience that
whatever we do they find a way to adapt
and will adapt to that and then they
adapt to that I mean it's a it seems to
be a pretty constant back and forth
Border Patrol's policy of separating
parents and children crossing the
southern border sparked a national
outcry this summer which Childress says
underscores the impact the press and the
public can have on policy so there were
separations under Obama no it wasn't the
the official policy to use it as
punishment
obviously Trump did try to use that
policy it was pretty short-lived as we
saw it when I left the grounds for
separating anybody were more relaxed
than they were under Obama so that's the
effect that the public outrage I think
has had is that when the people who just
won't tolerate it
it's going to have to change were there
any particular experiences that made you
start second-guessing this
tire Endeavour not actually an incident
where I caught somebody but after
they're caught they have to be processed
and I was assigned to processing one day
and as a routine part of the questioning
we have to ask
they have scars or tattoos and the guy
said he had scars and when he lifted up
his shirt to show me the scars there
were lash marks all over his back when I
asked him what those were from he
explained that he refused to carry drugs
for a smuggler and they tied him up and
whipped him for it I didn't feel good
about sending that guy back and that was
a dramatic example but there's countless
others that didn't have a dramatic story
like that that they just want a better
life and I stopped being able to
reconcile that what also changed his
mind was listening to podcasts while
driving around the border 8 to 10 hours
a day specifically a show called
unregistered hosted by historian and
recent contributor Thaddeus Russell one
particular episode featuring author and
sex worker
Maggie MacNeil made him reexamine his
fundamental beliefs and I've actually
had people go oh yeah a [ __ ] - I'll go
no no no I mean an actual prostitute
ring is gonna actually take money for
sex and then they'll be like oh oh oh
because they're thinking I mean [ __ ]
right how did the idea is being
expressed there changed the way you
started to think about your job so there
were two guests of feds that when I
first saw them I wasn't completely
thrilled I didn't really want to hear
what they had to say I thought and one
of those is Maggie MacNeil and Connor
Habib who's a gay porn star I don't have
anything morally against either those
lifestyles but I also didn't really want
to hear about it but once I finally did
download and listen to those episodes I
was blown away I mean they had so much
more to offer
and so much more to say than these
little categories that we put them in as
a pornstar or prostitute they're
fascinating people they're brave they're
smart they're heroic
this small bias in my mind almost
stopped me from listening to these
people's stories and how much enrichment
I got from listening to their stories so
then it made me start to take stock of
the rest of my life if I had these
biases that I didn't really realize I
had what else is there how do I really
feel about the drug war how do I really
feel about prisons and immigration
naturally came up as one of those
opinions and so what are your views
about immigration now I think we're
moving in the wrong direction I think
we're moving towards more restriction
more enforcement and I think there
should be less because Bryan Caplan the
economist says if there's not a good
reason to keep you out come on in he
basically says that if there's no
communicable disease no violent past
there's no reason that you shouldn't be
allowed to come in and try to make a
life for yourself I want to see a freer
world I want people to take charge of
their lives I want people to be able to
make their own choices and I don't want
an imaginary boundary to get in the way
of that they're being spoken about as if
they are pieces to be moved around or
assets to be utilized like know their
people deport all criminal aliens and
dismantle every last criminal gang in
cartel threatening our citizens we're
told from the Trump administration that
the reason that we need to get tough on
the border is to stop you know ms-13
members from coming over criminal
violent criminals and drug traffickers
and child traffickers those people do
exist and we we do come across them but
I no longer believe that immigration
policy or immigration restriction is the
solution
that problem if you have problems with
drug trafficking and violent gangs which
are also linked to do drugs most of the
time
well let's legalize drugs in the United
States and that takes a significant
amount of power out of those guy's hands
we can't fix the problem just by more
restriction Childress recently appeared
on Russell's podcast for a long-form
discussion about his intellectual
journey and ultimate decision to leave
the Border Patrol
he's now working on a maintenance crew
at an apartment complex alongside
several Mexican immigrants if what I
have to say has any effect I hope that
it is that people will take inventory of
their life and take inventory of their
views think about why you believe what
you believe and if you can go through it
and think yeah these beliefs are firmly
rooted good that's gonna help you sleep
at night that's gonna help you lead a
peaceful life but if it's not I think
that's valuable information to have
[Music]